yet another giant trailer has dropped
that I had no idea was being released
today so here I am again talking about
the trailer for Justice League I just
reviewed the trailer for Wonder Woman
and now we're getting a look at Justice
League for the very first time which is
interesting because Batman V Superman
and Man of Steel both were very limited
in regards to information we got and
they were promoting both of those movies
with little morsels of information
photos and small little images up to
like three years before they were even
coming out Justice League is coming out
next year and I'm extremely happy about
the fact that we actually got a
sufficient look at this film with the
past two films they were absurdly
secretive about various details that
they didn't really actually have to keep
under wraps it's really cool that this
trailer is actually a trailer it's not
just a shot of Batman standing in the
rain and Superman looking angry this is
a full fleshed out look at Justice Lee
again I got to say I'm excited and I'm
not just excited because I grew up
loving most of these characters I'm
excited because this trailer and Wonder
Woman both are definitely looking like
they have a vibe of fun and there is an
obvious attempt to make it look a lot
more upbeat than the past few DC Comics
movies we've gotten this one opens up
with Bruce Wayne trying to recruit
Aquaman who clearly is not very amused
with this conversation they're
definitely going with a more hardened
badass Aquaman because Jason Momoa
doesn't really say much of anything in
this trailer he just goes which worked
in this trailer it's really well edited
I like the fact that Bruce Wayne and
Diana Prince are teaming up to attempts
to find these various people now I am
actually a humongous fan of the flesh I
love this character I always have when I
was a boy he was one of my favorites I
loved the old TV show I would always beg
my mom and dad for action figures of
this character and the clip that we got
of him talking to Bruce Wayne in this
trailer definitely looks like they're
nailing that character he looks funny he
looks sarcastic and it looks visually
brilliant as for cyborg he looks great I
don't know much about that character
though he's never really been one of my
favorites but this movie could change
that who knows it is very clear that
with the most recent Suicide Squad
trailers as well as the Wonder Woman
trailer and now
this that DC Comics has heard fans
complaints and are attempting to make
their films more fun and a little more
upbeat
so my sincere hope is that we didn't
just see all the best jokes and the most
humorous parts combined into one trailer
to make it very fun I'm going to go out
on a limb though and be optimistic and
say that's not the case guys I got to
say as someone who watched this trailer
with a very skeptical eye I'm impressed
this looks good but I am going to remain
optimistically reserved because I have
yet to be blown away by the new DC
Comics universe of films but I'm hoping
that this one does speaking of DC Comics
films I just reviewed the Wonder Woman
trailer and I'm going to be seeing
Batman The Killing Joke on Monday can't
wait for that truly hoping it lives up
to the hype you guys are the best what
did you think of the new Justice League
trailer thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes